You are listening to
radio lab radio from W.
N. Y. S. T. E. N. N. P. R.
Okay. Yes. Listen to
this. Yes, for a second.
Is that Johnny Cash? Yes.
It's Johnny Cash and he's singing
a song about the deep importance of
mathematics in your life.
It's no math here. What
are you talking about?
You know there's a lot of math here
because you see what he's doing is he's,
he's moving to his extinction it seems,
but he's being very careful to calibrate.
Oh my God, we're going to go all
the way to one later. The scene,
this song for three hours already and
numbers are making it TD. I would.
I would, if I were him, I'd lose the
numbers. Blue blew the numbers. Yeah.
You can't lose that address.
You cannot lose the numbers because
numbers create order in your life.
Could lose the numbers. I could.
I could survive an entire, well,
my whole life without them. That's
just completely ridiculous. Easily.
No, try me. Try me. All right. Let me
just ask you something very simple. Yeah.
You go to buy some m and m's and you
have $5 bills in your hand and you'd give
it to the vendor and the vendor gives
you back the m and m's and what?
No numbers required if hand him
the bill. He hands me some change.
I just go by trust. You go by trust?
Yeah. He asked you how old you are.
What do you say? I'm
middle aged. I tell him.
Okay, listen to that. You hear that?
Suppose that you're late for an
appointment or something like that? Yeah.
So you call up and you say, I'm
going to be three minutes late,
five minutes late, 10
minutes late. How easy.
Just wait for the call before I
leave. I know that you know it's true.
I know it was true. So yeah, don't
eat them. Don't eat your test.
You're taking the test in school. You
get in 98 you get a 52 you don't care.
Pass, fail. How much gas is in your card
yet? I wait for the light to come on.
At what? What did you
want to call me? Right?
Yeah. And you can't remember my
phone number. [inaudible] News.
How many words?
Yeah, you gully use numbers.
Hi. Hello.
Is that how it ends? Yeah,
that's a great ending.
Ending made possible all
thanks to the discipline use of
[inaudible] and that's
going to be our hour.
What do numbers do to us and
for a don't to for us get the,
what do we have? We have a to have
a detective story. I love stories.
Some Nazis add lots of numbers. I'm
Jad Abumrad I'm Robert Krulwich.
This is radio lab. Stay with us.
Okay,
so Chad, do you want to
introduce the some this person?
And this is a, this is a
little Ameel. He's Emile.
So how old is he? He's hungry right now.
He's about 30 Carla, how old is he?
36 six at the time of this
recording he is 36 days old.
Well I've, you must have wondered,
do you think he has any sense at all
of numbers or quantities or do you mean
like thing? Can he count as
I'm asking you, you count.
But like do you think he has a, I
don't know, a numeric sense at all?
Do I think he has a numeric? No. No, I
don't think he knows that he uh, that,
that that is his hand that he's chewing.
I don't think there are any
numbers in there. In fact,
I'm pretty sure there aren't. No.
Whoa.
Lulu [inaudible] you should
introduce yourself to a meal. A meal.
This is our producer, Lulu
Miller. And by the way, Jed,
while you were on paternity leave, we,
we shouldn't Lulu on a
little mission to ask,
where does a number since come from and
how soon does it arrive in a person?
Hello? So this is the
first guy I spoke to.
His name is Stanislas de
hen speaking. Who is he?
He is a neuroscientist in Paris.
We've been brushing up my English
for a few minutes currently.
He's like the Godfather,
this research really?
He wrote a whole book called the number
sense that talks all about what babies
understand. Yeah.
And he said that for a long time people
thought that babies came into the world
just empty Piaget and many of the
sinkers so that there is with people,
I've called the blank slate that we could
only learn numbers if we were taught
them. Yeah, that's what I think. Good.
No, we know it's just completely wrong.
And how do they know this?
Well, experiments, right?
Well lots and lots of baby experiments.
The equipment we have is a
set of little sponges, uh,
which contain a very small electrode that
you can place on the head of the baby.
It's ready to net
and these babies are old. Um,
in this case it was a babies
of two or three months.
So he plunks the baby down front of a
computer screen and on the screen are a
bunch of little pictures. Uh, you
know, liter ducks for instance.
It's always a set of eight of the same
object. So you do eight ducks feet,
Dax Eight, ducks patriarchs eight.
And what he sees is that at first the
baby's brain is a little excited about
getting to see ducks. And then it slowly,
the firing just kind of fizzles out.
Another eight darks
and then at some points
underneath he changes it to trucks
and he sees a spike in
brain activity in the call.
[inaudible] meaning the baby
can notice that change. Yeah,
but that's not number. No, no, no.
I know he's just getting started because
Dan runs the whole thing again starting
out the same way. Great darks eight dogs,
eight but then instead
of changing to trucks,
he just changes the number
eight dogs, eight dogs, 16 dogs.
And once again the baby
notices the chain change,
but now it's in a different part of
the brain which we call the palliate or
lobe. So the suggestion
is according to Stan,
that they're noticing that
this is a different kind of
change that in some sense
they're noticing this
is a change in quantity,
which is very important because it
means that even in newborns they have in
their minds and in their brains
and intuition of numbers,
sure. That they're seeing numbers or
maybe they're just seeing a change in the
pattern. Some, some, some, some more.
We'll share what they're good at.
Is making these gross distinctions like
eight versus 16 let's say 10 and 20,
you know, and as the difference in
number gets smaller and smaller,
then they're not so good.
There is no baby, uh,
that will ever know the
difference between nine and 10.
These numbers are too close together,
but it's not quite as simple as
you might think. According to Stan,
which is most Xtandi know you.
I think the way that they're actually
experiencing quantities is not just a dumb
down version of what adults do.
It's a completely different
version of what adults do.
They seem to care about the
[inaudible] of the number. The what?
The logo [inaudible] of the number
you means logarithm. Yes. Sorry,
my English is getting
really bad at logarithms.
I don't know if the Swedish scare
that purely listens to this show,
but it's actually not that bad. You
can think of it in terms of ice shows,
everything about you meaning us,
how we think about numbers and imagine
in your head the distance between one and
two. Okay. What is that one right now?
Imagine the distance
between eight and nine one.
Also they feel like the same
distance from each other. Yeah,
but that's because we think of numbers
in these discrete ordered chunk. One,
two, three, four frog.
But now if you were to think about
it logarithmically like the baby,
the distance between one and two is huge.
Okay?
It's this vast space
and the distance between eight
and nine tiny. Why is that? Well,
because one to two is doubling,
but eight to nine until
you show off close to one,
I need one point something [inaudible]
okay.
Now, here's the spooky thing about this.
You might think what must happen
is that eventually as we grow up,
we just naturally switch from
logarithmic thinking to the numbers.
We all know now. But this is not true.
According to Stan. If
left to your own devices,
you'd never switch.
What do you mean you would stay
in this logarithmic world forever?
So we've done this, Eh, very
funny experiments in the Amazon,
uh, with people from the Amazon. We do
not count basically in their culture,
they do not have number words beyond
five and they don't recite these numbers.
So, um, uh,
what we found is that these people still
think of numbers in a low guide way.
Even the adults. What
that means is that, uh,
if you give them a line and on the left
you place one object and on the right
you place nine objects.
You got that [inaudible] and he asked
them what number is exactly between one
and nine. Okay, so you'd say five exactly.
But would they put in the middle
is three. Three. Oh wait, help.
Help me here a little bit. So the, uh,
the property of [inaudible] miss that
each time you multiply the number,
you move by your constant
displacement. Okay?
So this is a bit tricky,
but the gist is if you're thinking
in ratios and you're starting at one,
then you multiply by three to get
to three, right? And then, hey, hey,
you multiply by three again
to get tonight. I see.
So those are equal jumps on either
side. This leads to one as nine is two,
three, get it. Yeah. Well,
that's such a sophisticated way to
go about thinking about it yet to us,
but not to them. That feels intuitively,
simply like the middle dozens of
people did this without hesitation.
I mean this experiment gives me chills.
These are the numbers that we
all for want of a better word,
naturally feel. At least that
is, that has been my, uh,
[inaudible] go to claim for
many years. Hmm. And I don't,
I don't quite know how to phrase
this question, but is there some,
does it almost like the way
we think about numbers with,
with an equal distance between
one, two, three, four, five, six,
seven is wrong.
Hmm.
You know, I wouldn't go too far.
But then I talked to Susan Carrie,
I'm professor of psychology at Harvard
University and she said that numbers as
we think of them today
are certainly made up.
Those are human constructions and even
somewhat at odds with how we feel numbers
intuitively. That's right. They
are. So there is the problem then.
How do we ever come to understand
the numbers we know now that's a,
that's a $64,000 question.
She says it happens gradually.
Can you don't dish the microphone
over a couple of years? Can you count
one more quick introduction that is little
luck who you might remember from the
last year show. Yes. You've met marina
before and her mother, producer,
Amanda Aronchick. She will
be two in a week. Yes,
it's her birthday and we've called
them in today because of an experiment,
credibly simple set of tasks
that Susan told me about.
If you have a two year old at
home, you can do these tasks.
We're gonna play a game. Okay, so you
put a bunch of pennies on the tape.
I'm going to give you some pennies in
just a second note that let me get them
for you. And you say to the
child, can you give me one penny?
And I have one penny and the child very
carefully picks up one, enhance it. Gee,
that's right. That's one penny. Thank you.
Young two year olds almost all can
do that. Then you ask for two pen.
Can I have two pennies? No,
no, please can I have two?
And it doesn't matter what you ask for,
they just pick up a handful and hand
them to you when the two pennies you have
like one, two, three,
four and so they've given you four
pennies and you say is that too?
And they say, yeah right and then you say,
can you count how many
pennies? What can you count?
And make sure how many pennies
is that? So they go one,
two, three, four and you say,
is that too? She's they say yes
and sometimes they count. How many
pennies does that one, two, two, two.
So like Tom.
Now note that all of their other words
contrast with one in meaning that is
there,
they're giving you a number and they're
giving you a number of more than one,
but they haven't the slightest idea what
two is or three years or four years or
five is and they don't know what to
means for nine months and they're in that
stage for several months and then they
become 300 hours and then they become
four knowers. That process takes
a year and a half. In other words,
even though it sounds like
getting understands numbers like we do,
she's probably still living
in the land of that baby man.
But there does come a moment
when they finally step away.
Can you sing that song?
And it happens, right?
When the kids about three and
a half years old, what they do,
I think this is speculative,
but after years of everyone
around them saying, count,
can you count how many pennies you
have? This is something parents
do one too.
Discounting with with
children. Can you count
to ten one, five, six, two, four, five
[inaudible] and three
even though the kid is
baffled by the numbers,
five or six or seven board, five,
eight the line, the last one,
that some point, fair enough.
And they just sort of
throw up their hands,
believe the phone.
That's an a very
bold leap that children must make.
And so now what five means for
the child is one more than four.
Knowing what six means is one more
than five but now you've got integers.
We're all sort of like relying on
this song, like yeah, one, two,
just that one day decided, okay,
that means something. That's right.
So this is a trick.
What does she mean by that trick?
Sounds almost like a dirty word. She will,
she doesn't use it like a dirty word.
She says it's a wonderful trigger
point is once you have that trick,
you build on it
and that opens up the whole
world of mathematics to you.
And we can build buildings in launch
rockets into space and no other animal has
invented that trick.
But I can't help feeling there's something
about this that's a little bit sad.
Why? Well,
just the idea that to step
into this world of numbers,
we all have to leave something
behind. We do. We're born with, yeah,
but don't look what you get on
the other side though. You get,
you get to play and have remarkably
interesting. If you like math,
you get to play with deeply abstract
and beautiful thoughts. So yes, yes,
and that's great. But you feel sad
when somebody's good at trapeze work?
No,
that's just something that they're good
at and they practice it and they learn
it. It's just like different talents.
That's what Robert F I think I
know what Lily's talking about.
I mean it's refreshing somehow to know
that the numbers that we use day to day
are somehow made up because sometimes
the numbers for me at least feel like
these hard, fussy foreign
things that don't feel real.
They feel actually the opposite of
real. But you're sure sure. That
really isn't just unfamiliar or a little
strange. I mean foreign. Yeah, sure.
Cause when you, before you could
walk, when you were just a crawler,
you know toddling was kind of unusual
and then toddling became kind of an
adventure and then that became kind of
usual and then eventually you do walk.
But if there's something about
numbers where I feel lit personally,
I never learned how to walk.
And I think there was a lot of people
listening right now who probably feel that
way about numbers. So
maybe what does that mean?
They'll just logarithmic people. Come on.
It's five three five
eight (979) 323-4626 yeah.
Thank you very much for that lesson. Lily.
Stay strong in your
opposition to integers.
Paul. One nine seven one six nine three
nine we'll be right back. Seven five
0582097494 five nine (230) 781-6406
hello there.
This is Amanda and Nina and we are
going to read the credits so Camino,
you ready? Can you say Radiolab?
Radiolab is funded in part by
the Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
the corporation for public broadcasting
and the National Science Foundation.
I mean it.
Can you say National Science Foundation
Radio Lab is produced by W N Y C and
distributed by national
public radio. Good job. Okay.
Hi, I'm Robert Krulwich. Radiolab
is supported by Squarespace.
The simplest way to create
a website this new year,
make your next move with Squarespace.
Whether that's starting a business
or launching a passion project,
no matter what your goals are.
Squarespace's award winning templates
can help you present your ideas to the
world.
Beautifully use offer code Radiolab
for 10% off your first purchase of a
Squarespace domain or website.
squarespace.com make your next move.
Make your next website.
Hello, I'm Jad Abumrad and I'm
Robert Krulwich. This is radio lab.
We're still talking about numbers and
now we're going to switch though it may
be, it may fatigue. Some of us, if you
think about them a little differently,
if you learn to embrace them
and give them a bit of a hug,
wonderful things can happen. I'm
going to introduce you to a, um, well,
a nosy man named Mark Nigrini.
I'm an associate professor at the
school of business at the College of New
Jersey. Has a really heavy New Jersey
accent, but what he really likes to do,
what kind of accent was that was kind
of a, I originally grew up in Cape Town.
South Africa. South African? Yes. Oh, he
likes to play detective and the clues.
He looks for distinct numbers. I,
I can't walk past the number
without just wondering about it.
I went into that number.
How did it get there?
For example, after I finished
filling up at a gas station,
sometimes I would just walk around and
look at the dollar amounts on the pump.
So he peaks in at the pump right
next door and it's rather amazing.
You can almost tell
who's been there before.
If you see a number like
a dollar 40 then you know,
oh teenager with no money.
Why wait, explain that.
Cause that's all the kid
can afford. Quite right.
Sometimes I'll see $10 and 4 cents
and I'll say, oh you meant to be
$10 but you were a bit slow today.
So you'd go to the gas pumps tell
you all little short stories. Yes.
And his favorite story that numbers tell
actually starts back in 1938 so imagine
an office in Schenectady, New York
at the GE research laboratories.
And in that office is a man
and he's sitting at his desk,
Mr. Frank Benford and Mr.
Frank Benford is a physicist.
So he's doing some difficult
calculations and hunched over a book,
probably actually the one of the
most boring books you could imagine.
This is a book of logarithmic
tables. And what a logarithmic table.
So a lot locked tables where a very
convenient way of doing multiplication in
the early part of the last century.
So remember this is before
there were calculators.
So if you want it to multiply something
like 145 times 3,564 you could just go
to this book and look it up.
So it starts with numbers.
You might want to multiply by one new a
hundred on the first page and then 101
and two up to 200 and 300 and the back
of the book is like nine hundreds the
further you go,
the higher and higher the numbers
you use to multiply that trade.
So our Benford fellow,
he's sitting there doing miscalculations
and he's looking at the numbers
flipping to the bone. They staring at
the pages and this something clean.
You notice that the first few pages
were more worn than the last few pages,
meaning were smudgy and darker oily as
if he was using the front of the book
more than the last few pages.
Any wonder why is this happening?
Dreams. We're favoring one part
of the book over the other.
Am I doing something a little?
Huh? Where? Maybe it's something
and that's when it hit him.
He thought maybe in this world they
are more numbers with loafers digits.
Then with heifers, digits.
What more numbers that
start with one or two.
The numbers that start with seven, eight
or nine just because his book is more,
that's where, that's what started
him thinking, so here's what he did.
He compiled some tens of thousands
of statistics that Steve Strogatz
mathematician at Cornell University,
just anything he could think of that
was numerical molecular weights of
different chemicals, baseball
statistics, census data,
revenues of all the companies listed on
the main stock exchanges in America and
everywhere. He looked in all these
different categories. It seemed,
guess there were more numbers
beginning with one in twos,
that eights and nines
wait, really? Oh yeah.
This has been checked out again
and again and again and it's true.
It's eyes of rivers, earthquakes
and things like that.
Populations or a number of deaths
in a war, areas of counties,
stream flow data. What if you were to say,
get all the people in New York together
and look at their bank accounts,
bank account balances,
follow benfits loan Uri perfectly meaning
that if you just look in it amount of
money that people have,
matter of fact being all the bankers
you'll find they begin with one more often
than they begin with too. Perfectly. Yes,
so actually they begin
with one 30.1% of the time.
They'll begin with a to 17.6% of the
time they'll begin with a three 12.5% of
the time. That's a,
that's a big difference.
Why was three Eby I'm sorry I keep going
and the poor nine would any occur as a
first digit 4.6% of the time,
which actually would make
the one approximately six
times as likely as the mine
and he just quite amazing. That
is more than quite amazing.
That's deeply suspicious. I mean,
this is crazy what I'm telling you and
I can't give you good intuition why it's
true. But Steve and mark and many, many,
many mathematicians would tell
you despite what you may think,
there is a preference, a
deep preference in the world.
It seems for number sequences that
start with ones and then twos and then
threes. I'm Robert [inaudible]. Mm.
So what?
Well, this is not just a
mathematical curiosity, jazz noon.
I know there is something you can do
with this information. Right? Well,
when Mark Nigrini first
ran across Benford's law,
he thought, [inaudible]
maybe I can use this law
to bust people
for payroll fraud tax
return for you thought, hey,
we can use this to catch a
thief. That's right. Huh?
How willingly Nigrini figured if you
look at a bunch of numbers that they
bank statements or
expense reports and so on,
and you see that the numbers
in the business do not
match the natural pattern of
Benford's law.
So the numbers don't begin with ones
more than two's moving with twos,
one with threes and so on
could say, hey, this is not
natural. This may not be true,
this may be
fraud.
So we started giving lectures on the idea
that Binford is a way to catch these.
The only problem was they didn't
quite believe Benford's law,
which means the rest of my talk
isn't going to go anywhere.
It is now my great
pleasure to introduce you,
one of the most fabulous people
I've ever had the name to say,
Daryl d Doro
[inaudible] look [inaudible]
definitely, totally,
definitely lead illiterate to literally
of heaven. It's like palindromic. Yeah.
Itch Gerald Darell. Oh Wow. And um,
but I should say Daryl is a, what
did you call it? They calls it,
I'm a forensic accounting
forensic accountant.
[inaudible] which means his job is to
examine numbers and figures to see if
someone is stealing. It's
an investigative process.
And while at first he was unsure about
Benford's law, but skeptical. One day I
happen to talk to one of
my neighbors who was a, uh,
retired professor
and he said, Oh, Benford's I have my
students do that proof every year.
He actually wrote out the proof for
me. And it's just, it's immutable
mathematical law. And now it's one
of his favorite tools of history.
We have a case right now underway,
relatively small company,
family shareholders there four of them.
One of them feels like she has been
misrepresented as a shareholder.
Meaning she thinks these other three
guys may be stealing [inaudible] yes,
I yes. And I know you can't tell us what
this business is doing, but is it a,
it's a, it's a, a regulated business.
Uh,
it's a business that each of you purchase
on a regular basis through your local
governmental authority, trash
collection or Su Ranger.
Anyway, this one woman thought
that she was being cheated,
so she got an attorney involved.
The attorney requested data.
So we have seven years of income
tax returns and that's all he had.
Just tax returns. [inaudible] yes. So
he edited them all into the computer,
aggregates them, run Benford's
and clicked on the graph.
We instantly saw Vango
for a couple of the years.
Coincident with when the dispute began,
the way they've reported their taxes
violates Benford's very suspicious.
Yes. Blew out the Benford's pattern.
You mean like there are too many
nines on the tax returns? Meaning.
If you look at the tax
returns at this company,
you will see a pattern that
isn't natural. Exactly.
Not enough ones and too many
sevens, eights and nines,
but now you have to convince detectives
and then lawyers and then judges.
This is real evidence of wrong doing,
but they've not heard of this thing.
Benford's don't know about it.
As a practical tool has probably
been around maybe 10 years,
maybe 15 at the outset.
I'm at a conference now. What about 700 to
all of you here?
I've spoken four times and each
time I've asked about Benford's,
who's heard of it? Who's familiar
with veterans law? Maybe,
maybe 5% of the people. Can
you just look at pennies?
Couple observations to meet doesn't
make sense to exclude the community.
Use Ben for your same result
and they're asking you,
judges allow Benford's in as evidence
suggest that someone's committed a crime
case law out there that actually cite
the use of Benford and Daryl tells them,
oh yeah, yes, you can use this
evidence in court. Yes, federal,
state and local from the
experiences we've had.
And then he tells them stories like the
case of the CEO stealing money to buy
automobile firearms, wear jewelry
in Benford's and then you shoot you,
you're still in federal prison or
the case of the dentist and his wife,
she began having an affair with a guy
who turned out to be a meth dealer.
The dentist suspected her of having dipped
into the till run Benford's and boom,
busted.
She eventually pled or the guy with a
$40 million Ponzi scheme run Benford's
well almost boom. I mean, benefits
was an element in all these cases.
It wasn't the clincher,
but still it is a very compelling argument
and then 10 years from now it'll be
the equivalent of a fingerprint.
[inaudible]
that's it. Huh? W you still having
addressed the central mystery here,
why in the world, whether
it be more ones than nine,
shouldn't they be equally, uh,
equally coincident? Yes. Well,
the answer is actually very
complicated in deeply mathematical.
The simple answer is, is
there an answer though? Yes,
there is an answer and it has to do, do
you understand the answer? No. I mean,
I understand that it has to
do with logarithms and the,
and the business of doubling
and the culture of numbers.
But if you were to sit me down and say,
explain it to me carefully and, well,
I mean, no, it's just too new
metrics for me to explain it to you.
Okay. All right.
But I will now take a little sidestep to
a group of people who would be able to
explain it to us if
they were in this room.
But we didn't find them in this room.
We found them in, in other rooms.
We're rarely in the same
room that they are. Yeah.
So let's go with our reporter Ben Calhoun
and meet a crowd of mathematicians.
Ben. Yup. You decided to,
I don't know what some kind of a
busman's holiday you want, right?
They go to a math conference.
I did madly. And what happened?
Well, I went to CUNY, which is
the City University of New York,
and it was a math conference called,
it was on Combinator burial and
additive number theory. Oh, a good time.
Had by all, yeah. It goes by
the optimistic acronym. Can't.
So I had heard that if I
went to this room, no tables,
there was going to be a bunch of
mathematicians from all over the place.
[inaudible] from Sweden attending and
they would be able to tell me where they
condoms college, what their name was,
but they would have this other way
of identifying themselves. Right.
They had this number, my
numbers, two, three, two,
three, three, two minus three
actually. Oh, nice. Yeah,
I'm really excited about it. What, what
is the, what does it mean? Right too?
I'm with three. Well, it's an air
dish number. What's an ear dish?
Ear dish is a guy. Oh,
so your air dish number is how many
steps away you are from this Guy Paul air
dish. So you're going to tell me his
story. Yup. Hey, you ready? Okay,
let me turn off my cell phone
so we don't ruin the best cake.
That's Paul Hoffman. He wrote
a book about Paul Air Dish.
So we start out in Budapest,
Hungary in 1913 at spring,
two math teachers have a son
named Paul and he had two sisters.
They were three and five and they
had scarlet fever and they died
the day he was born. I mean,
imagine that his mother loses her
two daughters and gains a son.
Oh my God. Yeah.
She was so terrified after that that
Paul would get a fatal disease and die,
that she didn't let him leave the house
pretty much for the first 10 years of
his life. She didn't let
him play with other kids.
Really didn't let him go to school,
didn't let him go outside. Also,
when he was wanting to,
half his dad was captured and put in a
Soviet prisoner of war camp for six years
of his life.
So here's this kid at home
without other children around.
His mother is out teaching mathematics,
all the books in the house for math.
And he taught himself basically to
read by looking at these math books.
And he also said to me, the numbers
became my best friends. So I mean,
here's a kid who's, you know, whole
life is mathematics from the beginning.
But let's fast forward.
Paul Erdish gets his phd in his early
twenties this is in the early 1930
he's [inaudible]
Paul Air dish is Jewish,
which means he knows that he's
got to get out of Hungary,
that he managed to get
to the United States,
but he has to leave his family behind.
[inaudible]
when the Nazis moved into Budapest,
four of his mother's five
siblings were killed.
His father died as they were hurting
Jews and trying to move them into the
ghetto, and he only had his mother left,
but she was in Hungary and in 1941 Paul
[inaudible] was at Princeton University.
He was just 27 years old,
completely cut off from his family.
He was lonely and he was homesick.
I mean, this guy had no
conventional friendships.
He had no sexual relationships.
His only contact with the girl
was the people he worked with.
[inaudible].
I mean, there's,
what's remarkable to me is other people
who had been through this kind of life
experience might have ended up in a mental
institution or worse, but he didn't.
He turned this sort of inwardness into
making mathematics a joyous and social
occasion. He started connecting
with people, I don't get this. Like,
what do you mean? Well,
he started traveling.
He would hear about somebody who was
working on something interesting and he
would find a way to get
there, show up at their door,
and he had this phrase that he
would say, my brain is open.
And he was there to work with them on
whatever it was that they were working on
and he just kept moving,
made a circuit of 25 different countries.
Eventually he gave up almost all of his
possessions and he became essentially
homeless. He had no home, he had no home.
So everywhere he went people had to
put him up. And as a house guest,
the man was an acquired taste. He
didn't know how to do basic things.
He couldn't cook, he couldn't
even boil water for tea,
could barely change his clothes,
didn't know how to tie his own shoes
until he was 11 he had some kind of skin
condition, so they only wore silk,
silk clothes. You had to wash.
I mean he went through life this
way and there was the schedule.
He did mathematics 20 to 22 hours a day.
He'd bang pots and pans around in the
kitchen at 4:00 AM because he wanted you
to come downstairs and do more math.
So why would anybody want
a visit from this guy?
This sounds like a walking nightmare.
You have to cook for him or stay with
him and wash his clothes regardless of
your shoes, regardless of all of it.
You wanted him to come see you. Why?
Because he was just that good.
This was like God coming to visit
you. He knew your strengths,
he knew how you thought and it
was fascinating to watch him.
I mean there were times like I
went with him to a math conference,
aims there in his hotel room and at
one point there were like 10 or 12
mathematicians in the room.
Some are sprawled on his bed,
some are sitting on the floor and he'd
be working with one for a few minutes and
then he would turn to another and then
he'd go back to a third and he was
working simultaneously with all
these people in different problems.
Paul Air Dish wrote more
papers and collaborated with
more people than any other
mathematician who's ever lived.
He did mathematics with anybody,
even if the person was a dim bulb,
well did mathematics. Now let
me just, what's this people do?
This is Paul Arish on his 80th birthday.
That's the only dovish by an old man you
can say is no easy cue of the incurable
disease or fly surrounded by a lot of
the mathematicians who loved him and put
him up in their house. We
want to express our deep,
warm feelings to you and I want
to raise this stones for you.
He was a saint, I think a saint.
That's Joel Spencer. He's a mathematician.
He was also friends with Paul air dish.
Now that he is is gone.
I think of him sometimes in a
religious context because he,
he gave this faith to those of
us that are doing mathematics,
which after all is if you
look at it from the outside,
it's a little bit of a strange activity.
While you put this enormous
effort into finding these,
these statements,
mathematicians will spend years of their
lives trying to prove these things that
you know from the outside look
totally obscure and pointless.
And yet it was clear working with him
that what we were doing was we were trying
to find truth with the capital t truth
that transcends our physical universe.
I think that's the reason why we like
to about our connection to Paul because
our feeling of mathematics,
the feeling for what we want mathematics
to be Paul Erdish was the embodiment.
Somewhere along the way,
mathematicians started keeping track of
their connection to Paul air dish and
that's what air dish numbers actually are.
If you published a paper with
polarity, your erudition number is one.
If you published a paper with someone
else and they published a paper with Paul
Air dish, then your erudition
numbers too and so on and so on.
So this is like all the people that Paul
air additions some way has touched all
the people who are connected
to him through their ideas.
There are about 500 people with editors,
number one and about 8,000
people with their address number.
This is professor Jerry Grossman at
the University of Oakland in Michigan.
And what he did was he took each ring
of erudition numbers and he charted it
out.
Heritage number three has
about 34,000 people in it, uh,
about 84,000 with their addition number
four, then they start decreasing.
What are you done for the house?
And that's a lot of people.
If you go ring upon ring upon ring
in you and you do the whole deal,
like how many people did this
man in the end influence?
I think it's about 200,000 mathematicians,
200,000
[inaudible]
200,000. Picture that for a second.
It's like a solar system with more than
200,000 mathematicians all orbiting
around Paul Air Dish
[inaudible]
and your air dish number is one one.
Yes.
Dennis Eichorn is a number two
and the edition number is two.
I wrote a paper with uh,
my advisor and the other students and she
had written a paper with mathematician
who had written a paper with
parents. My oldest number is three.
Your air number is one and everybody with
heritage number one knows that they've
got that host. Everybody in
this room knows their number.
I would be very surprised if Kara
[inaudible],
Ben Calhoun's erudition number is oh
0.5778 dash p minus one Gallico six coming
up, a story from our
friend Steve Strogatz,
the mathematician from Cornell
who tells about a friendship.
He has a very precious
friendship with his math teacher.
So it's all about mathematician,
but this is a very unusual
friendship and Chad have,
I'm Robert Krulwich stick around.
This is Christine Stone
from Maplewood, New Jersey.
Radiolab supported in
part by the National Science Foundation
and by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science
and technology in the modern world.
More information
aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
okay. Okay. I'm Jana. Boom.
Rod. Hi, I'm Robert Krulwich Radiolab.
Our topic today is mathematics,
mathematics, and mathematics.
I suppose that is our topic,
but actually we do have a gripping
story for you coming up now from our
producers, Soren Wheeler. Hey, sarin
pate. And this is about math, right? Yeah.
Well math and friendship really.
And I heard it from Steve Strogatz.
He's a mathematician at Cornell University
and he's been on the show once or
twice. Okay.
And we sat down in the studio and he
told me about why don't you back up and
tell me a little bit about high school
and about his high school math teacher,
Don, Joffrey. Well,
there were several striking and
peculiar things about him. I mean,
probably the first thing is that he was
physically incredibly impressive when
would hold the chalk between his
enormous fingers and right on the board.
The chalk would pulverize with each
stroke so that there'll be this cloud of
chalk dust all over him and
his big sweater. And um,
another thing that was
very unusual about him,
he'd be in the middle of the
calculation standing at the board,
jock dust all over him as
usual. Then he would space out,
let me get a look in his eye, a kind of
far away look, and then he'd say, Oh,
this reminds me with the hush tone. Oh,
this reminds me of the time Jamie Williams
calculated the formula for the end of
term in the Fibonacci sequence,
and he gave me Jamie
Williams with a student.
He was just a couple of years ahead
of Steve and Mr Joffrey's class,
and that was part of the Mystique,
you know that now he was graduated
and it was as if the secret was,
was lost to the ages,
but the point was that he would
talk about a student with reverend.
With Reverend, yeah.
What was very thrilling about that is
that there was this kind of chain that we
were now becoming part of.
Yeah. So then I'm off to college
and it was, it started very early.
I started to write to him, it was
like an annual tidbit or dear,
Mr Joffrey, here's the gym that
I learned this year in math.
So Steve would write to him, Mr Joffrey
would write back, add something,
ask them a new question.
And that went on like that for awhile
with Steve kind of still being like a
student and Mr Joffrey
still like a teacher.
There was one moment though
where something new happened
where he wrote to me
asking for help.
He said a question came up in his class
about an elliptical swimming pool.
So you know,
picture a swimming often there's a
little border on the edge of the swimming
pool, like a piece of
concrete that lines the pool.
You stand on that part before
jumping in. And so the question was,
if you had an elliptical swimming
pool with a one foot border around it,
is the outer edge of the
border also on the lips.
Something about that really appealed
to me. It was a very nice math problem.
Probably there was a little
bit of a show off in me.
Like I thought if I could do this,
he's gonna say something Nice.
You'll become part of the, yeah,
maybe I'll enter the Pantheon.
They'll start talking about me. Like
they used to talk about Jamie Williams.
So I,
I stopped whatever I was doing and I
worked hard on that ellipse lips problem
and I figured out two or three different
ways to turns out it's never an ellipse
if it cannot be an ellipsis.
He sat down and wrote back to
Mr Joffrey about this puzzle,
but I didn't just show him the answer.
I wrote the answer in a very loving
and gentle way that was meant to be
empathetic. That is,
I know where you're coming from and I'm
going to just start from scratch to lead
you from where you are to where you
need to be to solve this problem.
In other words,
Steve acted like he was the teacher and
Mr Joffrey played along and this was
such a generous thing. In retrospect,
the humility, the modesty,
the kindness in playing
the role of a student.
It's like he knew that that's what I
needed and man, I loved it. I would,
I couldn't wait for the
next question and his,
Steve went off to graduate school
to become a math professor himself.
He and Mr Joffrey kept writing
to each other. In fact,
they were writing to
each other quite a lot.
There was one sequence in March of 1989
where we wrote to each other almost
every year.
[inaudible]
he sent me a puzzle. I worked on it. I
showed them a really beautiful answer.
He expressed kind of ecstasy
and seeing this answer
[inaudible] it was kind
of a mathematician's dream
correspondence of puzzles and
equations and Steve loved
it. But every so often
Mr Joffrey would break
the routine a little bit.
He would say things about that.
He was doing some jazz piano gig.
You would sometimes write
about, he had three sons.
He would talk about them a little bit
and you know, I feel embarrassed I,
it feels mean,
but I remember not liking those parts
of the letters and I didn't write about
that. I mean, I would say maybe I
was playing some tennis or, but I,
I have lines in some of my letters that
say after a few of those sentences,
okay, enough stalling,
here's the math problem.
But then in later years he would
almost pointedly ask me things like,
there was a time when he said that
rumor has it that you're engaged,
we wish you the best. If this is true.
And guess what? In my letter back
to him, I didn't say anything.
Do you remember like thinking
not to respond or just, well, I,
I can tell you what was going on,
which is that I was already, uh,
in couple therapy with
my fiance, you know,
like in that time the letters
were kind of refuge from all that.
That is,
we could go into this pristine world of
math where things are simple and logical
and well-ordered
there may have been part of me
that felt like I'll come on,
this is the one place
where it's all perfect.
But over the years,
that perfect world got a little less
perfect because his oldest son died.
Marshall died, Marshall
died when he was only 27.
And uh, I didn't ask about it.
Can you believe this? I feel so sick
about this when I think about it now.
So you would just write back,
oh I've got another plug,
got another math problem for
you. Look at this. Um, yeah.
And then more than 20 years into
this relationship letter writing,
Mr Joffrey retired and now that he
couldn't teach anymore, he'd write to me,
he'd show me these beautiful math
problems that he would make up from self,
usually about hawks flying
over the earth and you know,
how much severe Brickell area can
the Hawk see if it's at such and such
altitude. Um,
and what is happening at this time is
that now I have just gotten married and
we've started having kids and I'm
not answering his letters anymore.
They're sitting in our
envelope stacking up.
He's riding them faster than I
can answer them a lot faster.
And then at one point I got one
more letter from Mr Joffrey,
except as soon as I looked at the envelope
I could see that something was really
very wrong. His handwriting
didn't look normal. The,
my address, my name was written
in a craggy like shaky, shaky.
And I knew what that looked like cause
my dad wrote like that when he had
Parkinson's. So I thought,
what, what's this?
And I opened the letter and the first
sentence is [inaudible] I just had a mild
stroke. I didn't write
back to him right away.
I didn't call him. And then
just a couple months later,
my brother died very suddenly in and
he heard about it from someone else and
immediately wrote to me how,
you know that he was fair.
He and his wife had heard and they were
very sorry to hear that my brother had
died. That to me was um, you know,
I still had never said I'm sorry about
Marshall all those years ago and uh,
it kept nagging at me.
I want you to talk to him beckoning
and obviously care about him.
It's sort of like in math, there's
this concept of bifurcation,
which really means a fork
in the road, a splitting.
When the forces on a system get too large,
there can be a moment when the dynamics
of that system change abruptly.
Qualitative
[inaudible]
this was a moment of bifurcation.
We should've just said how sorry I
was to hear about about Marshall.
So I, I thought I got to
go talk to him and ask him,
can I come to your house? You know,
he seemed a little reluctant about it,
but you know, okay, fine. So I
bought a little pocket tape recorder,
just a cheap thing.
Drove up route 95 to his house in
Connecticut on the shore and knock on the
door, hear the piano that was
playing inside stop. He comes in,
rushes to see me and we
give each other hugs.
Take out a big plate of cold cuts
and say, let's sit out on the porch.
So that work. Hello? So we're,
we're eating and recording.
Then he takes out his German.
I decided that I would keep a journal
since I was retired where he's drawing
pictures of all kinds of birds and
there's a picture of me doing an ego watch
out in the Connecticut River and there's
a lot of stuff about [inaudible] and
his typical way, I don't know,
like this is a bird that's moved up from
the south too. You never saw these one.
What some people call buzzards.
Yeah, they've moved up here. And
uh, this is one of my favorite birds.
It's a marsh hawk and the
flies low over the meadows. Uh,
more about that. Hank says, ah,
I'm going to take you over to
see a rough legged hawk now.
He didn't say we're gonna see if we
can see a rough Leggett hawk. Yeah,
he produced [inaudible]
and I'm thinking to myself, I don't,
not really interested in this.
I want to talk about him, about
all these things that are,
that we never talked about that are
emotional hard things. Like what happened?
How did your son die? Yeah,
a lot of work.
They're just trying to make guys put
in extra hours to pay guys extra hours.
There was a fidgeting feeling inside
me and benefits and other stuff
and um, there was a pause.
My heart was beating fast
then I thought I'm going to ask them now.
I don't think we ever talked about
Marshall, but I want it at night. I did.
I asked what, I didn't really
know him either, but he,
I know that he died very young
and I what, what happened? No,
what happened to Marshall? Well wait,
you know, that's helpful. You don't
really want to talk about that.
And I think he's going to say that's
something we don't talk about well was if
he had ever met as a star,
did he?
He did. He had a wonderful 27 years.
Music was gone. It was
so beautiful. And so, um,
and so uplifting and sweet.
He'd be at home and we'd
sit around the piano
and I'll get out the Cole porter
song go can just turn to a page,
something that he'd never seen.
He could sight read it, play it,
and sing it all in one time
with us. And I thought, God,
this guy's got a multichannel
nine that I wish I had. You know,
he talked about what a great, what
a great life he had in his 27 years.
In his waning moments, he'd stay up
all night long playing the piano,
just the house, which is
filled with beautiful music.
And he had made plans to get a job at
the New England conservatory and things
like that. But the
faiths were wrong before.
Oh yeah, we miss it.
Was, was that, I mean in that moment did,
did it
changed the way you see
him or will it change?
I have to tell you how that day ended.
So we talked more and I
asked him at one point,
do you think Marshall
had a religious feeling?
And he said he didn't think he felt
close to having the come to terms with
somebody out there. Yeah,
that was a good thing that,
that I think he went peacefully.
Then actually conversation drifted to
easier things like calculus problems and
we talked to more about
math and then he said,
how about a swim or let's go to the beach,
go out to the beach and I
could do something where I
get outdoors a little bit.
So we did go to the beach and um,
it was a beautiful evening and there
were waves coming in from long island
sound. In fact, we were talking
about a math problem about waves,
about fourier analysis,
which is really about,
well infinity in the fact that if you
take an infinite number of simple waves,
you can create any shape of wave you
want as long as it's a wave that repeats.
But then Mr Joffrey asks,
how do you create waves that
don't repeat waves that change?
Sometimes waves don't exactly
repeat. They can grow or die out.
And Steve told him that to
deal with those kinds of waves,
you need a different kind of infinity,
not the kind where you just keep
adding and adding and adding numbers.
But the kind that sits in the
space between two numbers,
this higher kind of infinity than
don had thought about before.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
thanks. Juicer and wheeler, because you
interviewed Steven produced that story.
Thanks to Steve Strogatz
who has the book out now,
which tells this very story
called the calculus of friendship.
I'm Jad Abumrad meaning seconds to
do. You are Robert Goldberg. Bye.